[Música]
familiares y ciudadanos rusos
despidieron a mijail gorbachov en el
cementerio donde fue sepultado sin
honras de estado ni la presencia del
presidente vladimir putin el último
líder de la unión soviética falleció el
pasado martes a los 91 años su cuerpo
fue velado anteriormente en el icónico
salón de las columnas de moscú
miles de personas salieron el viernes a
las calles de argentina en apoyo a la
vice presidenta cristina fernández de
kirchner después de que un hombre
intentara dispararle a quemarropa este
jueves la jornada había sido declarada
como feriado por el presidente alberto
fernández en tanto avanza el proceso
contra el sospechoso que ya está bajo
arresto
la agencia espacial estadounidense nasa
retoma este sábado su intento por lanzar
una misión no tripulada hacia la luna la
denominada misión artemis 1 el objetivo
es preparar el regreso del ser humano a
este satélite en france 24 hacemos un
repaso sobre el programa lunar
estadounidense
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 si rodrigo se dar hoy es un
gusto acompañarlos abrimos esta emisión
en moscú en donde el cuerpo de mijail
gorbachov el último líder de la unión
soviética fue despedido por familiares y
ciudadanos en el cementerio donde
recibió sepultura junto a su esposa tras
fallecer el martes a los 91 años y
aunque no fue programado un funeral de
estados y tuvo el reconocimiento de ser
velado en el mítico salón de las
columnas moscovita en donde tuvo lugar
el velatorio de otros líderes soviéticos
tras la muerte del ex líder soviético
mijail gorbachov vladimir putin no tardó
en expresar sus profundas condolencias a
través de un lacónico comunicado del
kremlin sin el clásico telegrama a la
familia y allegados una acción que
muestra la ambigua relación entre los
dos dirigentes veamos más en el informe
la imagen ha provocado especulaciones en
la última década en mayo de 2012 cuando
vladimir putin fue investido presidente
por tercera vez mijail gorbachov asistió
a la ceremonia está firmado pero nadie
sabe lo que dijo a partir de ese momento
se volvió un muy crítico con el
presidente ruso y sostuvo que tres
mandatos presidenciales son demasiados
un año después habló públicamente del
tema en una gala en su honor en eeuu y
luego en un programa de radio
yo aconsejaría a vladimir putin que se
fuera ya ha tenido tres mandatos dos
como presidente y uno como primer
ministro tres mandatos son suficientes
se están creando clanes a su alrededor
vladimir putin habló de la caída de la
urss como una gran catástrofe del siglo
20 con una crítica velada a su último
líder no obstante mijail gorbachov apoyó
a vladimir putin durante sus primeros
años en el poder e incluso le aconsejó
apoyó sus esfuerzos para que nuestro
estado sea más eficiente con el fin de
establecer orden en el país cosas que se
pueden cuestionar pero creo que su rumbo
es el correcto
en realidad la relación entre los dos
hombres fue ambigua
en lo que los dos hombres coinciden es
en la necesidad de ampliar la influencia
internacional que le pertenece a rusia
legítimamente en lo que son radicalmente
diferentes es en que putin no es
comunista bajo ningún precepto mientras
que mijail gorbachov era un comunista
convencido el ministro griego volver
atrás
gorbachov no llego a decir mucho sobre
la guerra en ucrania su fundación emitió
una declaración dos días después del
inicio de la invasión rusa en la que
pedía el fin de los combates y el inicio
inmediato de las negociaciones de paz no
obstante unos años antes gorbachov apoyó
la invasión rusa de crimea
la empresa alemana siemens desmintió las
razones de la rusa gazprom para
suspender el flujo de gas a europa a
través del gasoducto nord stream 1 las
peronas asegura que una fuga de aceite
detectada en una turbina durante las
tareas de mantenimiento impiden la
entrega de gas sin embargo si mens
asegura que un problema de este tipo no
es razón para suspender la actividad del
gasoducto y que las fugas pueden sellar
se in situ incidencias de este tipo en
el pasado añadieron no conllevaron el
cierre de la actividad de la tubería
y siguen las protestas contra la
formación del gobierno y los
enfrentamientos entre facciones chiítas
en irak los más mortíferos en bagdad
durante años la complicada situación
persiste incluso luego que múqtada al
sádr el líder del movimiento chiita que
ganó las últimas elecciones y que instó
a sus seguidores a levantarse contra la
formación de gobierno anunciará que se
retira de la vida política por todo ello
el primer ministro mustafa al kadim y
declaró que dejara su cargo si no mejora
la situación del país
mojado
mena y advierto que de ahora en adelante
si quieren seguir promoviendo el caos el
conflicto la discordia y sin escuchar la
voz de la razón daré mis pasos morales y
patrióticos de anunciando la vacancia de
mi cargo en el momento apropiado de
acuerdo con el artículo 81 de la
constitución de irak y los ares
responsables ante irak y ante la
historia
si movemos la mirada hacia china en
medio de la restrictiva política de kobe
0 dirigida por beijing cerraron partes
de la ciudad en shenzhen y el transporte
público de la urbe una más de las varias
ciudades que han vuelto a estrictos
confinamientos lo que hace esperar que
la recuperación económica del país
asiático será más lenta de lo esperado
en total los habitantes de 6 zonas de la
ciudad que suman buena parte de los 18
millones de personas que habitan la urbe
deberán hacerse dos pruebas de kobe 19
para rastrear la transmisión del virus
desde este jueves también fue confinada
a chendo
hablamos ahora de américa latina'
argentina vivió multitudinarias
manifestaciones en favor de la
vicepresidenta cristina fernández de
kirchner quien fue víctima de un intento
de asesinato con arma de fuego en la
noche del jueves en diversas partes del
país los argentinos tomaron las calles y
las plazas para condenar el ataque
rafael pérez nos cuenta más
nombre resonó este viernes en argentina
cristina fernández los periódicos del
país presentaban en sus portadas a la
noticia que recorría el mundo y que
generó una jornada de masivo apoyo a la
vicepresidenta víctima de un fallido
intento de asesinato la plaza de mayo-
se colmó por completo banderas con
mensajes de aliento imágenes de eva
perón y música marcaron la jornada
ayer nos salió una bala por una cuestión
técnica
evidentemente porque estaba todo probado
de que la bala tenía la intención de
salir y esa bala es el resumen de un
discurso de odio al presidente alberto
fernández declaró feriado el viernes una
luz verde para todo el que quiso mostrar
su respaldo a la líder peronista la
posibilidad de que a cristina le pueda
pasar algo
realmente es impensada para nosotros
realmente nos salvamos no sé de algo
terrible que no puedo ni siquiera
comprender qué hubiera pasado si a
christina le hubiera pasado a la noche
enojo
es el más cuidado de la presidenta
vicepresidente haciendo
nuestra bici no tendría que tener más
custodio más
está bien que ella se deba en público lo
hago como el dicho pero
tengo una muestra más de apoyo a alberto
fernández visitó a la vicepresidenta que
más tarde a pesar del peligro que se
cierne sobre ella se volvió a acercar a
la multitud que la respalda en el barrio
recoleta hace más de diez días incluso
sus opositores más férreos como el ex
presidente de mauricio macri condenaron
la agresión contra cristina fernández
en costa rica las solicitudes de asilo
rebasan la capacidad de la oficina que
los tramita los migrantes de la vecina
nicaragua huyen en busca de un mejor
futuro un fenómeno que supera las cifras
de los años 80 cuando las guerras
civiles obligaron a cientos a huir de
sus hogares andrés granadillo tienen los
detalles un sistema colapsado debido a
la cantidad de solicitudes de asilo de
nicaragüenses en costa rica por lo que
la agencia de la onu para los refugiados
ayuda con personal el sistema de refugio
de costa rica ha tenido dificultades
para hacer frente a ese incremento tan
importante de solicitudes de refugio que
ha habido desde 2018 en la que hubiera
apoyado el gobierno de costa rica
mediante la contratación de 50 personas
en la unidad de refugio que ayudan a
procesar estos casos y hacer frente al
rezago ahora de tantos años este por la
acumulación de casos las peticiones
suman unas 200.000 una cifra que
representa el 4 por ciento de la
población costarricense y son más de los
que hubo en la década de los 80 durante
el éxodo ocasionado por las guerras
civil en la región unas 50.000 personas
están esperando cita para hacer una
solicitud formal costa rica con 5
millones de habitantes fue el segundo
país después de estados unidos en
recibir el mayor número de aplicaciones
de asilo la cifra se ha incrementado
desde 2021 cuando el presidente
nicaragüense daniel ortega arremetió
contra la oposición y encarceló parte de
ella costa rica sigue siendo la primera
opción para los nicaragüenses que
emigran un mayor motivo de juego por
beneficio de trabajo
trabajito que uno puede lograr a tener
allá
es complicado y todas para mantenimiento
de la familia
y gracias a dios aquí en costa rica nos
dan el apoyo de
trabajar y ayudar un poco más a la
familia
muchos de ellos al ver la demora en sus
peticiones ponen sus ojos hacia eeuu y
méxico donde esperan lejos de casa tener
un futuro
vamos hasta eeuu allí la tenista local
serena williams perdió el viernes ante
la australiana águila tool janowicz en
nueva york' y se despidió del usopen el
partido de tercera ronda del torneo
podría ser el último de su inmensa
carrera considerada ampliamente como la
más grande de todos los tiempos semanas
de cumplir 41 años su retiro aún no está
claro y luego del partido personalidades
de dentro y fuera del deporte le
enviaron mensajes de admiración
el deseo de ganar una y otra vez es la
marca que ha convertido a serena
williams en una leyenda del tenis
pero esta vez la campeona perdió ante la
australiana tomljanovic en la tercera
ronda del usopen fue probablemente el
último partido de su larga carrera tras
un anuncio de retiro el mes pasado
aunque todavía dejan duda cuándo será su
salida de las canchas al insinuar que
podría jugar el slam australiano en
enero
no lo sé no estoy pensando en eso sin
embargo siempre me encantó australia
pero si sabes que he recorrido un largo
camino desde el año pasado en wimbledon
solo que no estoy segura de si ese fue
mi último momento o no hacer que sea un
momento diferente creo que es mucho
mejor
en el de forma en que es much perder
en todo caso su paso por el open un
momento único para los aficionados
es la más grande de todas no creo que
nadie pueda igualar la lo que ha
conseguido no se puede comparar en el
deporte para mujeres o para hombres
estamos muy orgullosos de ese barco
ha tomado su decisión está en la cima de
su carrera a los 40 años es una de las
mejores atletas del mundo estamos muy
orgullosos de ella y no importa que haya
perdido
desde su derrota en los homenajes no
paran de llegar de deportistas como
tiger woods serena williams eres
literalmente la mejor dentro y fuera de
la cancha gracias por inspirarnos a
todos a perseguir nuestros sueños te amo
hermanita o personalidades de la
televisión estadounidense
25 años campeona heroína eres una
leyenda para siempre con 23 títulos de
grand slam y 6 años en el número 1
serena williams habrá forjado uno de los
mejores palmarés del deporte mundial y
este sábado la nasa realizará un
lanzamiento histórico la exploración
espacial a casi 50 años de los últimos
pasos en la luna el ente espacial
estadounidense revive un segundo
programa con la meta de llegar a nuestro
satélite natural pero con la mirada
puesta en el espacio profundo de cinco
días hubo ya un intento fallido de
lanzamiento pero los equipos de tierra
de la misión artemis uno en el centro
espacial kennedy en florida
haber solucionado los problemas de
ingeniería veamos de la mano de rafael
pérez los comienzos de la historia del
programa lunar estadounidense
desde que el ser humano inclinó su
cabeza hacia las estrellas tuvo el
anhelo de pisar la luna como una muestra
de poder el reto fue protagonista de una
rivalidad geopolítica en una carrera
librada por eeuu y rusia
creo que esta nación debe comprometerse
a lograr la meta de antes de que se
termine esta década colocar un hombre en
la luna y retornarlo a salvo a la tierra
ningún programa espacial en este periodo
será más impresionante para la humanidad
o tan importante para la exploración del
espacio a largo alcance el programa
tendría un nombre mitológico apolo el
presidente kennedy fue asesinado ocho
años después de presentar el proyecto y
no pudo observar el triunfo
juan a este torneo
pero eeuu de un paso gigante en nombre
de la humanidad el honor correspondió al
comandante de la misión apolo 11 neil
amstrong después del viaje de amstrong
12 personas pasearon por la desolación
de los campos lunares el último en
hacerlo fue eugene cernan prometiendo
volver en paz y con esperanzas para toda
la humanidad antes de cumplirse 50 años
de esta promesa la nasa lanza un nuevo
programa lunar llamado arte mis hermanas
de apolo en la mitología griega como
parte del nuevo proyecto el lanzamiento
del cohete space launch system portador
de la nave orion abrirá una nueva página
de la historia de la exploración
espacial la meta para el hombre en esta
ocasión es el espacio profundo
hasta aquí las noticias sigan conectados
a france 24
[Música]